we want to remind the public that it
will take a few days to fully return to
normal
we urge people in affected regions to
only buy the gas they need
so that we can help speed up the process
the gas price has not been this high
nationally since the last time joe biden
was in the white house
we do not believe the russian government
was involved in this attack
but we do have strong reason to believe
that the criminals
who did the attack are living
in russia the russians need to fix this
problem if in fact it emanated from
there
it's ridiculous to think that we should
just let this go away
let's bring in our panel charles lane
opinion writer for the washington post
morgan ortegas former state department
spokesperson matthew contineny
founding editor of the washington free
beacon welcome to all of you
morgan i'll start with you how do we
deal with russia if this is being sold
not as an official
state-sanctioned act but something that
emanated from within russia's borders
well i think any of us who worked in
national security find it hard to
believe that the
uh that these cyber criminals and
hackers i like to call them cyber
terrorists actually
uh are living and working in russia and
that the government isn't
at least aware of these attacks so
obviously i'm not privy to what the
government's doing behind the scenes but
i think at a minimum
we could start demanding that these
hackers be extradited to the united
states
we need to start putting in a level of
deterrence lindsey graham talked this
week with brian kilmeade
about how he wants to put forth
legislation uh that these
cyber hackers be treated as terrorists
and really i think if you look at what
happened this week we saw
just how vulnerable our critical
infrastructure
is and you really have to ask yourself
what's the difference between a suicide
bomber
you know blowing up one of these type
pipelines or the cyber hacker that takes
the pipeline off for several weeks of
production
so i think it may be time to rethink how
we treat these people to put in a level
of deterrence so that
the russian government or any government
feels the pain for the hackers on their
soil
charles these concerns have been raised
before but until it really happens i
think to a lot of people and there have
been millions who have been
scouring for gas stations waiting in
lines paying elevated prices
it brings it back to the forefront what
can the bind administration do
to in some way learn lessons or
institute new principles or policies
with respect to the cyber hacking
threats
it reminds you a little bit even though
the cause was different of how all of a
sudden the electrical grid went out in
texas
this winter we're discovering new
vulnerabilities to our energy
infrastructure all the time
i think it's problematic to cooperate
on a security matter with vladimir
putin's russia
no question about it that would be the
ideal solution if you could somehow
induce them
to turn over these bad guys but you can
never be sure that that government is
going to play
straight with us so i expect actually
the bide administration to emphasize
that this is part of why we need
an infrastructure bill or maybe you need
to readjust
the infrastructure program that he's
already suggesting
to devote more federal resources to
hardening
our systems so that they're not
vulnerable to criminals in the first
place well matthew one of the accounts i
read of the infrastructure proposal said
that it actually didn't contain things
that would have helped
in an attack like this um is there an
opportunity there for the bind
administration to still sell the
infrastructure maybe make some changes
to it
that package with this in mind i guess
so i mean
shannon for me this week has just been a
reminder of how
driven by events this administration is
you know the biden team really thinks
that they can control the message
but we've just been reminded again and
again in the past week
about how mugged by reality
they are by the events i think something
happened when biden visited
former president carter a few weeks ago
because it's
like deja vu of the 1970s and a preview
i think
of what might happen uh if some of these
biden policies uh continue
i want to play a little bit of the back
and forth that got us to where we are
now the latest with the cdc mask
recommendations and then we'll get some
reaction
what we've done is we've empowered the
american people to make their own
decisions about their own health this
probably could have been done about a
month ago
i assume the inflection point hit they
probably got some political direction
and they made the change
the cdc the doctors and medical experts
there
were the ones who determined what this
guidance would be based on their own
data
and what the timeline would be that was
not a decision directed by
made by the white house it was informed
the white house was informed of that
decision
all right i want to work around and get
a quick comment from each of you on the
mask timing
uh so we can get you to winners and
losers as well matthew we'll start with
you on this one
well i'm too happy about the news to
really be concerned about the
politicization
but i do think that if there were
politics involved it might not have come
from the white house but the cdc itself
because it's been looking at this
drop-off in vaccination rates
and maybe it finally realized that its
messaging was completely wrong you
needed to incentivize the vaccines
not feel like you're punishing people by
forcing them to wear masks
i mean charles with that and the
announcement about getting back to
school's full
bore in the fall it seemed like a lot
lifted at once
yes randy weingarten the president of
the american federation of teachers has
been dragging her feet
about allowing people back in school all
of a sudden holds a press conference and
now she's all in on it so look would it
be a surprise that politics influenced
this
of course not politics influences
everything
but i do think there is a valid
underlying reality here which is the
vaccine
it is taking hold resistance is going
away a little bit
and this reflects that okay morgan final
comment from you on the masks and then
kick us off with your winner and loser
well shannon i've spent a lot of money
invested in cute masks including some
very cute lily pults or masks that i
don't know what to do with anymore
so you know i guess i'll just donate
them to charity okay
my winner of the week uh is my very very
dear friend elise stefanik
i am so happy for her to be number three
in the house republicans today
beyond being a millennial awesome woman
congressman
she actually has done a lot to recruit
women
around the country to run as republicans
and i believe we had more republicans
than ever so
uh thank you elise for doing that and
congrats my friend i am so proud of you
and your loser uh my loser is
rob malley biden's iran envoy this week
it was uncovered that about 12 years ago
he had an interview
where he said that hamas was merely
misunderstood
so it's a bad week for that to be
uncovered a bad week to be negotiating
with iran whenever hamas is supplying is
shooting these rockets into israel
all right gentlemen so we don't get cut
off charles to you quickly on winner and
loser
then matthew my winners my co-winners
are benny thompson and john catko
leaders democratic and republican of the
homeland security committee who have put
together
a proposal that might fly for a january
6 commission
my loser is congresswoman green from
georgia who
managed to exceed her previous record
for unprofessional conduct up on the
hill by sort of
chasing down uh alexandria ocasio-cortez
in the halls of congress and has also
been caught on video a couple of years
ago
behaving weirdly outside her office too
matthew my winner is elon musk for his
star
turn hosting snl and my loser is rebecca
jones the mainstream media purported
that she was a whistleblower accusing
ron desantis of fudging kova data a
blockbuster report in national review
this week shows that she was a fraud and
it just as a reminder shannon if you
comment ron desantis
you better not miss and there are plenty
who
are and are looking at him as a 2024
target as well
matthew charles and morgan thank you all
very hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else